[Music]
in conspiracy theory news oh I do not
know this
Oh submitted by open your eyes
that was a scene on American mean were a
asian guy in a china at a Mexican gang
is doing a hit inside jail and when he's
stabbing the guy on the bench press he
goes open your eyes ensue
what do you excuse he was the Asian guy
in the Mexican Mafia oh yeah that's why
it was funny oh well it was an Asian guy
saying that yeah yeah it was an Asian
guy saying open your eyes it's it are
you stabbing him Wow it's the best thing
ever
damn I got watch that don't son Kings
tavern really yeah Mortal Kombat okay
the same the same oh we gotta play but
you actually named the real Asian actors
that confuse everyone
shame songs sang the bad guy the bad guy
your soul is mine yeah yeah there was
Johnny tsunami ah nobody oh yeah my bad
son King the real one
that's his voice no that's the guy yeah
yeah that's I mean if they're the same
guy
Mortal Kombat yeah when he was younger
that's crazy he's like the most Asian
looking [ __ ] ever
he looks racist how Asian yes when he
was walking around he walks around like
there's a gong every footstep mmm
American mean you know what's funny
there's always like one Asian guy in
that hardcore Mexican gang and his name
was Chino oh yeah of course
I had a friend that grew up right here
in Boyle Heights and he was from a
notorious Mexican gang he was a Japanese
dude yeah but his name was Tina yeah of
course I mean you know you know that's
when I went to Paramount like my first
year there as a
Jeannot Jeannot average there's always
one Chino I wonder if there's ever a
showdown between chinos from rival
Mexicans doesn't in luck
just she does look see there's Johnny
tsunami right there Kagawa damn alright
third generation damn he's one of those
Asians though that could be Japanese
Chinese Korean everything yes sure I see
it all except our Filipino except for
Filipino I mean actually Filipinos be
looking kind of like like Chinese
sometimes to like believe like
fair-skinned and you know I'm saying if
that dude shave that first half of his
head he could work as a railroad guy
yeah back in the day yeah if he if you
had like a buzz cut you could be like a
Korean liquor store owner true there's a
lot of me you were all just Chinese to
the rest of the world dog they don't
know we are unfortunate I'm actually a
bizarre conspiracy theory suggests that
many celebrities have gotten a black guy
black eye as part of the induction into
the Illuminati what more they just deal
with domestic violence like a
[ __ ]
or they all been training MMA at the
same place is it the Fight Club yeah
Fight Club I don't even know if the
Illuminati is real I think that there is
something like the Illuminati that's
real but it's not the Illuminati because
how are you a secret society that
everybody knows about true well let me
know when you get out when you get up
there because you know you're your
closest but you know we're just I'm not
near closer at Illuminati status I don't
even do cocaine yet I'm not even cocaine
successful yet you are hopeful though
did you hear that sentence
so maybe you got to do a few orgies and
some blood blood sacrifices or something
and Dan you can get in there yeah it's
got prove to them that I'm like you're
one of them yeah would you join even
know you guys do weird things I don't
want to do it alright so there's this
conspiracy that they're saying that
Illuminati recruits are forced to eat
pain during high-level initiation
rituals so they're pretty much having
their soul sucked out of them
their left eye and that's why they have
guys on their left eye and in worthy
yeah there's a ton of celebrities that
have had black eyes over the years okay
it's like Adam Sandler how they know
that's my Photoshop makeup get me some
of all my right eyes but they're
claiming the left eye here
so then well the hell is that wait
George Lawes boy George
he's mad George now dad he's gonna be
grandpa George soon fun I don't know
does a black guy should look just like
makeup David Bowie that's on the right
side buddy all right Pete that is that
just what does she got punched for so
Audie and then no they kick them out
they came out Robert Downey jr. what if
a lot of these dudes just party alive
and they just fall and hit their face
all the time have reasons yeah but you
know conspiracy theorists barrel but
that is kind of weird though because I
have not the pole because like that's
[ __ ] weird one of them they were like
oh he just woke up with it like real
[ __ ] weird cuz how many of us had a
black guy I was just gonna say that
think about all your friends no one has
actually ever got a black eye and
there's a lot of people that are
commenting to like I act like this one
person was like I get in frequent fights
and I think of my entire life I've only
had like one or two black guys I have
never gotten the black guy I've only
gotten a black guy cuz I had an accident
but that was it yeah the [ __ ]
probability is just crazy like how
[ __ ] a lot of politicians and Royals
have had black eye that's pretty [ __ ]
weird I've never had a black eye he said
he was punched by a man manager
I believe yeah yeah so I don't know
[Music]
reflexes I don't know man ability is he
still really popular I don't know he
lost a lot of weight he's skinny now I
feel like after TMZ he kind of became
irrelevant right cuz everyone's just
kind of doing what he did yeah he was a
big reporter right like a like a
gatekeeper like gossip like a gay King
stuff yeah yeah yeah what keeps our is
this straight
Perez or the straight Perez yeah yeah oh
yeah sure these are the way around oh
yeah he's getting its mind blown all
tied up because he was first yeah that's
true yeah I don't know man I do kind of
it feels like a really subtle but like
painful way to you guys have never
watched that I Love Lucy episode where
they both get black eyes like we know
that it's possible like how do they both
get it
so he throws a book at her like cuz he's
in the kitchen or something like that
and then he throws a book and she misses
and it hits her in her eye oh and
everyone thinks he hit her because and
then they're like because no one would
believe before the book all right happen
in real life what happened in real life
like you do let's not talk about that
guys wow dude still magical yeah I love
it I know Isaac's been on an I Love Lucy
binge you just love me crap oh that's so
cool yeah it's so funny I love touch
like hearing him he's like oh his age I
was too stupid to understand I was
I was too stupid understand to you bro I
love sounds like [ __ ] five turn this
boys [ __ ] but now I like it
I got watch it with her now I get it
yeah but as a kid I was like these guys
yeah it's all way too much god damn
I used to whenever they get into like
shenanigans and [ __ ] up the house and
I'm like you're so irresponsible this
frustrates me I remember being a kid
thinking if they only communicate it
they would avoid so I know I would be
like damn it Lucy why don't you just
listen just listen Lucy you tell them
how you feel instead of coming up with
this crazy plan listen you're a grown
woman doing some kid [ __ ] my mind was
blown I didn't know she had two more TV
shows after I Love Lucy that was all
centered around Lucy's yeah that was the
Lucy show I was like in color and I
could hear her voice
is she a redhead yeah real life no no
real hairs brunette all but she dyed her
she even jokes about that in the show
yeah she dyed it red yes so the so the
colour pictures that we see her that's
her dyed hair then yeah yeah okay yes so
now she was definitely in the Illuminati
for sure yeah yeah I mean spring about
the black eye they wrote an entire TV or
so did she put falsies lashes I wonder
now if there's like different levels to
the Illuminati cuz like I wanna see I
would think so stop right when the
pedophilia stuff happens so right before
that so like maybe I'll do the goat
killing stuff
I'll do the orgy stuff I'll even get the
black eye that's fine but then right
right there when it comes into like
there's really your soul cuz that's like
pretty much the whole thing I feel my
soul already on you too
I don't believe in that [ __ ] like saying
that all supposedly like all this how
you gonna stall something that don't
exist there so they're saying that your
soul like you give your soul to the
devil and immediately a demon takes over
so it's not even you anymore
Oh God and that's how they're successful
I'm not Scientology happen to him I
think Scientology's party I feel like I
join you illuminate before I joined
Scientology I don't know I'm just for me
I'm all about the gossip and the secrets
you know what I mean I want to get in
there get as deep as I can learn all the
secrets and then maybe I couldn't do
some [ __ ] real reporting but then but
then they'll come after you for life bro
you know okay they say that's why I like
you know like my faith is death to get
away from the Illuminati and Michael
Jackson faked his death to get away from
illuminati it's the only way out I'll
just tell my my family like yo I'm doing
something to change the world it's okay
if I use your like if you can't be
trained right like it's cool right and
they're like yeah let's do it
I bet you don't be down now I don't know
what's her name David with Scientology
via Romanian yeah who that is you called
docu-series
she was into Scientology as she
explained the levels the King of Queens
yeah yeah yeah it's [ __ ] interesting
bro the whole Scientology [ __ ] is kind
of quick documentaries this on Netflix
yeah yeah I'd she was in there she she
was in there she got out and she's like
the first celebrity that's opened me
like I can't Scientology what is it
called I forgot I forgot about yo you'll
find it yeah it's very interesting she
explains the tears and how things work
how they manipulate you talk to your
family yeah I don't even like talking to
my family but if someone tells me not to
talk to my family that's already a red
flag I'm a punch him in the stomach I'm
like yeah I don't talk to them but not
because of you [ __ ]
how do you become an undercover cop in a
little Minotti thingy so you're still
playing for the good team you just walk
up to the door with a black guy already
Oh like oh Sid all right cool the Saul's
already gone Wow their Security's pretty
what if what if though like the
Illuminati was the one keeping world
peace that's why we haven't been in a
big war for a long time right everything
they're doing is for a reason and we
just don't know it
yeah but then they have to kill goats
for it I don't know why do you keep
sacrificing things I think they kill
goats honey I just feel like something
cool like I don't know every time it's
the animal sacrifice
no but whenever you use you see like a
[ __ ] Illuminati thing you you see
them bleeding out goats or sunchokes go
to the dog goat I don't know what the
foot I don't know why it's gotta be a go
looks like the devilish maybe the cow is
too big to drag in the gold I tied to
the devil I mean why can't it be like a
koi fish or something different you know
like it's octopus offering like that
motherfucker's crawling oh my god I want
to see how the BTS of like all the
animals go through the drive how about
some grasshopper so they get a bag of
grasshoppers and they [ __ ] let it
loose and everyone's trying to catch
that [ __ ] and slam it alright
that's why they probably did this before
and then they go alright what's the
scariest kind of animal we can sacrifice
yeah they make sense
[Music]
[Music]